le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
entreprendre une carrière
professionnelle et l'objectif de
beaucoup de jeunes désireux de réussir
dans la vie
pour y parvenir on pourrait croire qu'il
suffit de trouver un travail à la sortie
de ses études et d'évoluer au fil des
années en théorie c'est aussi simple
mais en réalité les obstacles sont
nombreux pour qu'un jeune trouve du
travail rapidement
un des problèmes majeurs c'est le manque
de postes disponibles dans le
département réunionnais alors comment
trouver un travail dans un domaine
saturé à la réunion on en parle
maintenant d'un lien social
c'est dans le quartier de la source
qu'émilie et thomas se rendent aucune
arme avec beaucoup d'espoir parents d'un
bébé de 15 mois est soucieux d'apporter
un équilibre est un exemple à leur
premier enfant
il se bat depuis longtemps pour trouver
un travail
mais à 20 ans avec peu d'expérience et
dans des secteurs d'activités saturer
les portes se sont fermées
ne trouvant pas de travail à la réunion
et milliyet au mas n'ont pas lâché et
ont décidé de faire le grand saut pour
avoir une situation
ils se sont donc adressé aucune arme
pour les soutenir dans leur projet de
vie après des formations et des
entretiens
ils ont tous les deux été retenu pour un
travail en métropole dans la même
société et dans la même région
c'est avec fierté qu'ils nous racontent
leur parcours à la réunion c'est
difficile de trouver un emploi
donc c'est pour cela qu'on s'est tourné
vers le cloud et le cnps armes
on a connu le cnar grâce à mon frère il
est parti il ya deux ans grâce au cnam
on a vu aussi les publicités aux bus au
site internet
on a suivi une information collective
qui ensuite j'ai suivi d'un entretien
d'embauché après on a passé notre ca de
bosch
ça s'est très bien passé on a eu la
réponse rapidement et voilà aujourd'hui
on a la réponse que
on est pris on est très content et très
heureux un nouveau projet à trois
bassins s'installer là bas on est très
heureux et l'aventuré continue en france
comme emilie et thomas juliette a
rencontré les mêmes difficultés pour
trouver un travail à la réunion
tanase courageuse elle a décidé elle
aussi de se faire aider par le tarn
après des mois de formation elle fait
aujourd'hui son entretien dans gauche
l'enjeu est important pour elle et c'est
avec une certaine angoisse qu'elle
attend son tour j'ai choisi le tarn tout
simplement parce que j'ai été intéressé
par la mobilité ça m'intéressait
beaucoup étant donné qu à la réunion
mais pour trouver un travail c'est très
dur
et puis comme je suis motivé j'ai envie
de voir autre chose ça m'intéresse
beaucoup changé diao si c'est pas mal
j'ai passé un entretien avec un
recruteur qui est venu de métropole
je croise les doigts pour que je sois
route retenu pour parra siens parce que
j'ai vraiment envie
je veux vraiment j'ai envie de réussir
et j'espère que tous les réunionnais qui
souhaitent vraiment partir ben au moins
ils auront la chance aussi
s'ils veulent par axione n'hésitez pas
si vraiment policière c'est la chance
elle c'est la clé juliette sort de
l'entretien heureuse
sa candidature a été retenue à partir de
ce moment elle peut se projeter dans un
avenir professionnel en découvrant en
plus la métropole et pourquoi pas
l'europe
malgré la crise de l'emploi à la réunion
les jeunes ont des qualités et des
compétences que les recruteurs étrangers
et français viennent chercher le pain
armes est un service de qualité
il s'est formé et préparé la jeunesse
réunionnaise au monde du travail un
outil incontournable pour les recruteurs
et tout naturellement nous sommes
retournés vers un verre le cnps armes
pour nous aider à recruter des talents
réunionnais pour travailler sur
différents types de métiers en métropole
donc le normes favorisent bien
évidemment toute la place partie
logistique l'intégration des gens et
surtout la présélection des candidats et
c'est vraiment collaboration que l'on
travaille avec avec ce partenariat comme
dans toutes les régions de france
l'emploi est un combat quotidien
grâce à des dispositifs comme le tarn le
conseil général soutient l'emploi à la
réunion en proposant des aides et des
solutions
et comme vous le savez le tarn et
l'association de référence du conseil
général qui favorisent la mobilité des
rayonner à l'extérieur de l'île afin de
leur permettre de trouver un travail et
d'être épanoui sur le don de leurs vies
professionnelle et privée
cet organisme soutenu par le département
de la réunion permet à des jeunes des
moins jeunes d'avoir des parcours de
contrat de travail en métropole avec
pour les jeunes qui par exemple sont en
alternance des dispositifs de soutien
qu'il soit intéressant pour eux parce
que non seulement nous les préparons la
mobilité mais nous les accompagnons
individuellement en terme d'accueil en
métropole mais nous les accompagnons
financièrement puisque nous leur donnons
un complément de revenu est de pouvoir
d'achat
et parce que nous aidons les entreprises
à mieux les accueillir aussi en
demandant ces entreprises d'avoir un
regard spécifique ass et ce sont ces
jeunes chaque année c'est plus de 800
emplois qui sont proposées aux
réunionnais avec différentes
destinations
le kn armes a pour fonction principale
d'aider les jeunes à trouver un travail
mais il apporte aussi une chaleur
humaine nécessaire à cette jeunesse
parfois en perte de motivation grâce à
son personnel dévoué et dynamique le
tarn offre du courage et de la volonté à
ces jeunes qui de retour au pays feront
la réunion de demain
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais